I was getting out of the shower at home
that was dripping in the phone call and
I was thinking maybe I just want to
answer that but then I thought I had a
suspicion and I did answer it and it was
quite as quite a surprise then I woke my
wife up and I said I apologize to her I
said I don't know if I should wake you
for this but I just won the Nobel Prize
and she said you're kidding I had people
telling me that I might win it but
they're friends of mine so I then
decided I'll ask other economists seed a
well-known economist do you have friends
telling you that you're going to win the
Nobel Prize and they always said yes so
I figured it meant nothing and I have
friends telling me that